[Music]
go to sexual thirst trap Instagram chef
it's just [__] Owen seems we're done
yeah oh this guy yep
just filth
why
[Music]
don't let my husband know I'm watching
this yeah
[Music]
we'll be no see now see that's [__]
gross
what I want to see in one of these man
I want to see someone thirst trapping
some food in the middle of it they just
slam their [__] titty right in the
food just [__]
yeah put a [__] ball sack out yeah
why didn't he [__] why didn't he
actually [__] yeah yeah you're gonna do
all this other yeah
it's a grapefruit
I want to see a horny ass couple just
[__] that food
go all the way yeah you know stop
censoring it if you're gonna finger uh I
know you're [__] melon yeah dude pour
your cereal into a Fleshlight and eat
that [__] yeah I identify as a coconut
he would be the reason I'll agree to eat
anything
who are these people man how are you at
the same time so sweet and polite and
such a destructive tasty devil
my heart can't take you but the rest of
me wants to who is this man I don't have
legs I have two coconuts please spread
them
he's not gonna see that oh you're you're
out of here if you don't think he's
reading every single do you think so
yeah yeah yeah he's doing it for
attention come on man
you know what's funny is he's reading
those ones it's like be my boyfriend
he's like say something horny I don't
want to [__] I don't want commitment
[Music]
first of all that move so gross that
move the
like the the windshield wiper I've only
ever seen that in porn
that's the only you only ever see that
in the squirting videos yeah yeah
if you also have to be at that angle
yeah
but you can't do that from like the
normal when you're like making out
you're gonna be in front of it
or let's not be right here you're like
just
I mean if you're committed you could no
no but you're it's it's so distinct
I mean Play It Again
[Music]
laughs
I had to take a sip that [__] made me so
thirsty
what a [__] destructive tasty devil
dude
these aren't insane man
it's just the smacking yeah
he's beating his meat come on
holy [__] just man horny like
middle-aged women just
just damn I wish I was a piece of wagyu
right now I wish I was a pound of
brisket right now
I say women but really it could be
anybody watching this
it's pretty targeted at women you think
yeah he could have jerked off that
character that's true yeah
yeah
ah cucumber man see what he does with it
yo in the middle of me just sits on that
cucumber oh holds it pulls it out just
cutting it
he smells it
it's a real quick cut of him shirt let's
lower himself onto it
targeted at women oh damn
if you're just listening
um basically what he's doing is he's
making uh like a pork bow bun and then
he repeatedly keeps touching it like
it's labia
yeah
it does look good I mean all the [__]
that he's making that yeah and then take
out uh yeah yeah he keeps going down and
just taking full tongue licks yeah of
the stuff that he's making
like he just tongue [__] the foam on
top of a beer yep
damn
I'm just jealous because I wish content
was this easy for me I wonder how
individually found this we should make
one of those cuts with like I don't know
our version of that people would be like
it's not funny don't ever do this again
yeah yeah that would be disturbing yeah
it'd be like your um sex appeal is zero
and your presence in this media is
[__] revolting and also the food
looks like it sucks ass
never attempt to sexualize anything
again you are disgusting and awful to
look at it's microwaving a Pop-Tart nah
dude just a liquor lick a fork and stick
it in toaster strudel dude toaster
strudel and we just make that thing bust
all over the street
dribbling it out
no shot he promoted his kid man no way
really what does it say
oh oh that's him him oh
I'm like that's crazy in the middle of
like licking videos like by the way
here's my family
this was the first sexy one oh
click it
yeah come on now totally normal
[Music]
hey it's just him and all his friends
just slapping me like yeah we had to
tone it down
yeah so like zero percent horny oh
man what do you think the what do you
think the turn time is on one of these
to shoot it
the turn time yeah like start to finish
setup lighting a couple hours probably
probably taking you four or five hours I
think but yeah baking also takes a
really long time sometimes yeah
let's not discredit this guy's hustle
you know the videos are I mean the [__]
he's making look delicious it must be a
dessert Chef somewhere nice there's
actually a genius way to leverage your
pastry degree
because you're not making [__] from a
restaurant yeah
you know
he he probably started dude nice cooking
is never he's really leaned into this I
mean bro you gotta figure he got into
this he had a genuine passion
and he's like I love pastry I mean I
don't I'm not I'm not necessarily
against it
oh no I'm just a little bit obvious
there's a there's a I mean there's a
really weird like crossover between
horning horny content and cooking
content yeah like every Chef does this
yeah
they do it for comments like they will
like finger a brisket and slap you know
they all do it but this guy I could see
doing like a cookbook where it's like
half pastry recipes half like a horny
calendar yeah that would [__] sell
like crazy Josh Weissman man what are
you waiting for yeah give us the nude
cookbook bro